thank you so actually before I start my
my talk talk I want to spend a couple of
minutes to tell you what the plan is for
the boot camp like in terms of what
topics we plan to cover so you already
saw we had a beautiful intro talk that
kind of Cheyenne kata saying nothing
what do you want where are you going and
that's part of the reason we call it a
cluster because we don't know where is
it I don't know we don't know what we
want it's kind of a new topic and
prolonged was describing kind of things
that seem to be interesting related to
high dimensional expanders they seem to
be connected to PCPs they seem to be
connected to local testable codes we
don't really know and we want to you
know just tell us what we do tell you
what we do know and what we maybe you
know maybe more people and come up with
more interesting things so it seems like
this amazing object you know when I
first heard about it I was shocked
because I was sure such a thing cannot
exist and so you know it's interesting
but we don't know exactly where it goes
and I think or at least maybe codes is a
good day playground for playing with
these objects maybe they're it can be
useful for constructing interesting
error correcting codes that's why we
titled the cluster around this
connection high dimensional expanders
and error correcting codes so initially
the bootcamp was structured in a way
that today we will hear about expanders
and codes and also tomorrow but because
of the schedule shift today will be less
about codes and tomorrow will be more
about code so tomorrow for let's talk
the whole two hours will be about
different kinds of error correcting
codes and how local testability works
and where a expanders come up this will
be in pre let's talk tomorrow
there's the talk that I'm doing today
followed by your Tom's talk after lunch
we'll be about spectral definition of
high dimensional expanders continuing
stuff that for let us say in the morning
but going slightly more in depth so this
will be a sequence of three talks I will
give this first hour and then your
tongue will talk today and tomorrow
about the spectral treatment of high
dimensional expanders and then there's a
different notion of a high dimensional
expansion it was actually studied before
this and this is this go home illogical
expansion and only Wagner we'll talk
about that tomorrow and the other talk
that we will have about codes is a
survey talk by Mary waters she will talk
about open questions this is what the
bootcamp
will cover and so this talk the time now
starting would be just talking about
spectral definition of high dimensional
expanders so as Prahlad said when you
talk about expander graphs there are
many different ways to define expander
graphs you can talk about edge expansion
and you can talk about the spectrum of
the adjacency operator you can talk
about vertex expansion and all these
definian you can come up with other
definitions and all of them are
equivalent so we never really take the
time to distinguish between them but
once people start think about the
expansion in hyper graphs when you look
at each definition and you try to
generate it to generalize it hyper
graphs you get some definition of
expansion for high progress and these
turn out to be non equivalent so maybe
each one of them is is different from
the other and so it kind of caused in
the beginning in the beginning there
there were many works that try to
understand the relationships between
these and which one should you focus on
which one is the interesting one so this
is the sequence of talks will focus on
the spectral definition as Prahlada try
to describe this this seems to be useful
for us
so the basic object that we are talking
about is a situation a simplicial
complex consists of a bunch of layers oh
there's the empty set and then there's
the vertices and then there's the edges
and so on up to some dimension D and let
me start by drawing a picture of an
example of a simplicial complex so here
we have the vertices a B C D and then
the edges are a B AC BC and I have here
three triangles this is one triangle
this is one triangle and this is one
schoiar complex of dimension 2 I have
here faces of size 3 and dimension two
faces of size 2 and faces of size 1 if I
want I can say maybe ABC is one triangle
[Music]
jeez another triangle
then I have all the edges so I have a B
BC
it's
and then the CD and
yes we got one two three four five six
and I have all the vertices ABCDE and
finally I have the empty set over here
if I want I can put the edges for
incident so this this face is incident
it contained this face and this face is
contained in this face and I get here a
multi-layered picture which is similar
to the picture that for a la drew except
his it was 90 degrees rotated like this
he had the empty set of vertices the
edges and the triangles and then I like
to do it like this so that when I talk
about going up I go from C to AC so this
is a simply shut complex one way to draw
it is like this in a very different way
to draw it is like and now what I want
to try to understand is what does it
mean for this thing to be high
dimensional so before I do that I need
to talk not only about simplicial
complexes but about weighted simplistic
conferences where I have weights on
their faces so even if I put a uniform
weights on the faces on the triangles
if I look at the kind of the correct
weight to see what's going on in the
edges suddenly non-uniform weights arise
on the edges so there is a natural way
to start from a distribution on the top
faces and to go down to distributions on
all the faces below and this is also
something that we're not talked about
it's just you start by choosing a face
from the distribution over the top faces
you choose a random triangle and then
you remove you knock out one of the
vertices so you get an edge then you
knock out one of the vertices you get a
vertex you knock out one of the vertices
you get back so it's like you start from
one of these triangles one of these
three okay say BCD and then BCD has
three edges in it BD CD and BC edges so
you knock out the vertex it means you
choose one of these three uniform okay
and then suppose I chose BD so I can go
either to D or to B and then I go here
so essentially what I'm doing is I'm
choosing a random path going from the
top triangle all the way down to the
entries what I have is a distribution or
a Joint Distribution over a triangle and
then an edge and then a vertex in three
dimensions I have a Joint Distribution
over D plus two is the last one it's not
interesting
all right so let's calculate the
probabilities in this specific example
even if I put one-third so uniform
probability on each one of the subspaces
we need to see that this edge
participates in two triangles so it will
have slightly higher probability than
say this edge which participates in only
one triangle that's for example this
edge its probability is going to be one
over nine so you need to choose this
triangle and then move here and this
edge is also one over nine this edge has
probability 2 over nine all the edges
here have probability one over nine
except for this one ok so I mean there's
eight edges so indeed this describes the
probability distribution over the area
if I continue to calculate probabilities
for the vertices you would say that this
vertex has higher probability than say
this vertex so I get some kind of a
weight on all of the this is what we
call a weighted simplicial complex
the nice thing about talking about these
weights is is that you now have if you
start with any probability distribution
let's denote it by D over the top faces
this one can be uniform or not whatever
it is it already induces for you
probability distributions over all the
remaining dimensions these are really
like the marginals of this process he
start from here and then you go here you
get a distribution on the next layer and
so the nice thing about considering
these distributions is that now instead
of thinking about this process by choose
a triangle then an edge then a vertex
and then nothing you can reverse it you
can first choose a vertex but you're not
going to choose the vertex uniformly you
would choose it according to the
distribution here then you choose a
random edge that is incident on this
vertex and we move on and so on and in
these choices are all going to be with
respect to this distribution it's
important to kind of keep this in mind
it's okay to pretend that your
simplicial complex is regular in the
sense that every edge is participating
the same number of triangles and every
vertex participates in the same number
of triangles if this was the case then
all these distributions would be uniform
but in reality we don't know how to
construct high dimensional expanders
that have this very strong regularity so
because we don't have such constructions
we are forced to talk about weighted
simplicial complexes that and we need to
worry about these weights but the point
is is that this is just a technicality
because once you you just allow yourself
to have these distributions you you know
how to move back and forth you start
from here and go down or you start from
here and go up it's just like when you
work with expand your graphs we like to
talk about the irregular graphs because
then all the distributions are uniform
but it's okay to also talk about non
regular graphs and then the distribution
will be whatever it is
so in now that I have this definition of
weighted simplicial complexes I want to
talk about their local structure the
title of this talk out of the frame is
going to be spectral link expansion
so in general we are trying to come up
with a definition of expansion for
high-dimensional that generalizes the
spectral definition of expansion in
grass well that kind of hinted or showed
that a nice way to do it is by looking
at random walks but in fact in my talk I
am NOT going to talk about the random
walk definition this will be explained
in depth by your tongue vision that I
will focus on today is has to do with
link expansion okay by defining stands
and through expansion of the link so
what are the links
that simplicial complex there you can
kind of look at small local parts of
this complex small local parts of this
complex are the links they correspond to
something like the neighborhoods of a
vertex so what is exactly a link a link
is when you look at the vertex and you
look at all the phases that contain this
vertex this is the link except you need
to remove the vertex from these phases
for example if you have a vertex link XV
is going to be just a all the phases s
in X such that s Union and I'm writing
here this dot do you know two disjoint
Union and looking at all the phases such
that when you add V to them you get a
face in the complex I prefer to think of
it the opposite way where you look at
all the faces in the complex that
contain V and then you remove you from
it so this is the link the best way to
understand what this is is by looking at
a specific example so here I have my
complex and the vertices are ABCDE F
right so let's look at the link of a ok
so I have here X survey what is X of a I
need to look at all the faces in the
complex that contain a and then to knock
out a from them so one face is the
triangle ABC ok so I I have here a B it
was the face sorry BC
it was the face ABC but we removed a so
we were left with B see what other faces
are there that contain any so there's
the edge a see it now became just C and
there's the edge a B so it now became
just B so this is kind of formally what
it is but what is the picture the
picture is just this VC okay so the link
of a is just the graph on VC so really
what is going on here is that you look
at all the neighbors of a these are
gonna be your vertices in your new
complex here it's B and C and then you
leave all the edges that connect between
them this is in the case of a two
dimensional complex in general if I had
a D dimensional complex then the link of
a vertex will be one dimension less
complex so D minus 1 dimensional complex
of course on the picture it doesn't
really make sense to think about the
link of an edge the link of an edge will
just be one vertex the link of the edge
AC is just all the faces that contain AC
it's just the triangle ABC so you will
just have this one further when you have
higher dimensions it's also interesting
to look at links not only a vertices but
of higher faces anyway this is the link
of a let's look at another example what
is the link of D
okay right here so XD this is the vertex
D so who are the triangles that
contained it's this one and this one and
so it's easy to see that the link is BC
and this is the link the interesting
thing is that when you have a constant
degree complex or a constant degree
expander then these links are always
going to be graphs or complexes of
constant size very very small okay one
of the fascinating things about high
dimensional expanders is the fact that
you can look at these constant size
objects these links and based on their
features suppose you know some
information about these links you can
sometimes deduce some global information
about the entire complex for example
there is a theorem of Oppenheim that
your tongue will describe later today it
says that if you know that the graph is
connected and that the links themselves
are expanding it means that the entire
graph is expanding this is a very
strange and kind of amazing theorem that
you only know local information about
the neighborhood of every vertex and
this is enough for you to deduce
expansion of the entire graph which is a
very global statement so this we will
see this afternoon and my goal is to
prepare the ground in the sense of
giving the definitions to make this
statement format so let's start with
this what does it mean to say that if
you know that the links are expanding
usually when people talk about expand
your graphs they think about an infinite
family of graphs with a number of
vertices going to infinity and there is
some notion of a constant amount of
expansion that stays constant where the
number of vertices goes to infinity here
we are talking about links that
themselves have constant size so what
does it mean for the links to be
expanding so first of all certainly this
picture cannot happen because here this
link is disconnect
okay so you know for sure to not expand
so for starters we want all the links to
be connected connected is not enough for
us and we want to have some notion of
what it means to be expanding since the
title of this talk is spectral expansion
it makes sense to require that the links
have spectral expansion okay so I want
to talk about I want to give some a
reminder of what it means to be a
spectral expansion for graphs but for
this I want to go back and remember that
I started with a weighted complex so
it's not enough to draw the links like I
did now I just drew combinatorially
which vertices and where the edges are
but I need to also tell you what are the
weights if I had a weighted complex and
I look at the link the link itself is
itself a weighted complex so what are
the weight so it was a natural thing
there is a if you look at the top faces
of a link there is a one to one
correspondence between the top faces of
say the links and triangles that contain
a general I guess I should show it here
in the formal definition there's a
one-to-one correspondence between all
the asses of the highest dimension and
all the asses of the highest dimension
and if these are the sets of highest
dimension in our complex a triangles
then we already started with some for
which dispersion on all of the triangles
and so we can look at the probability
distribution on all the triangles that
contain V for example and then fry it we
get a preventive inspiration on all of
the edges in the link clearly enough but
what I mean is this if I look say at the
link of X
like a week see link of say thank you
it's just it has these two triangles
contained see so the link contains a V
and I want to know what is the what are
the correct ways here so look at all the
triangles that contains C there's two of
them and they have equal weight so I
associate equal weight to this edge into
this edge I just need to normalize it
because these two weights don't sum to 1
so I need to renormalize by all the
triangles that contain C and I get a
probability distribution here and I will
have half and half on these edges
Thanks
what is that you just conditioned on
only the top faces that contain your
face you're you're localizing and then
you you recalculate them why are we
doing it this way this allows us to
complex it's some kind of convex
combination of the complexes of the
links right yes a function on the
triangle function on some of the faces
we can decompose this function to convex
combination of functions on very local
parts and this somehow becomes very
useful when we do so when I talk about
the link I always talk about a weighted
link and the weights are our inherited
from the weights of the okay so now I
know what a link is and I want to define
what what it means to be a spectral high
dimension that expanded so first of all
I need to remember what it means to be a
spectral expander right for a weighted
graph so you know I'm sure all of you
know this but since it's a bootcamp and
I want to have everyone on the same page
I decided to spend some time when
reminding us what exactly we mean by
spectral expansion on a weighted graph
[Music]
[Music]
so you said you find white one way to
get the weights and the new complex in
other ways to condition on the single V
the re-weighting is it always consistent
so the two condition on the thing so if
you're looking at the link of a vertex V
what you should do is condition on on V
right but then you need to also remove e
the toxins first condition just on the
top level and then see what goes on the
all the way down in the limb or
condition the original field just on V
it's two different procedures right but
it turns out to be the same turns out to
be the same yes but what is not the same
and kind of might be confusing is to say
look I'm going to look at all the all
the faces that I got in my link I'm
going to look at their weights and just
renormalize this is a different process
and it's not this one is not the same
for example if you look at this example
here if you look at the link of D okay
notice that this Edge has weight 2
ninths and this Edge has weight 1/9 okay
so the link of day we drew it like this
without weights so what should be the
weight on these two edges in the wrong
process that I don't want to do I will
look at the edges the way they are
written and I see here two nights and
here one night so I'll put here double
the weight that I have here but this is
a not correct thing to do the correct
thing to do is first look at all the
triangles that contain D and look at a
distribution generated by them and after
you normalize and this will give you the
same weight on this edge in on this way
you can see that this is a better way to
do it because it will allow you to do
pose the graph correctly if you look
from the point of view of D and from the
point of view of a this edge will appear
twice so only half of the way it comes
from here and half of the way but I
guess the most important thing about
looking at the links is that on one hand
they're local and on the other hand you
can kind of write the entire complex by
combining them correctly I want to talk
about I want to remember what exactly
does it mean to be a spectral expander
graph expansion
so yeah so if you have a graph
what we usually think about is the way
to give us a distribution over the edges
so it's the same as having a
distribution so I mean I'm not thinking
about negative weights the way it's must
been and then you can renormalize and
you have a distribution over edges and
then you always look also at the look at
the just distribution over the
well and start with the way the graph
this is immediately that the data that I
am given is distribution over the edges
and I get from it very easily a
distribution over vertices which is just
what is the district what is the
probability of V I add up the
probability of all the edges inside into
V and I I guess I I need to divide by 2
because each edge gives half of its
probability to thee and half of its
probability to the other guy so that's
the standard a marginal distribution
over there now what we have usually is
we look at this adjacency operator of
the random walks
that tells me if I if I have if I'm
standing at the vertex V what is the
probability to move to a vertex a I need
to take the weight of the edge from V to
u and divide it by the weight of all the
edges inside internal to U is the
probability of U V divided by the sum
over all the neighbors W of the
probability of W V how you move from V
to u and what is the adjacency operator
it's an operator that acts on functions
of the adjacency operator takes a takes
a function on the vertices say a real
valued function and then it averages so
suppose I call this adjacency operator a
yeah so this is the operator when you
act on F it gives you a new function on
the vertices that's defined by a F at
point V is the average over all the
neighbors so I a bridge over all the you
inside and on V of f of u I think what
does its average mean it respects this
probability distribution it's not that I
go over all the neighbors and I give
each one of them equal weight no of
course not I need to respect the weights
on the edges so here's I'm doing
summation over all the use of the
probability to move from V to u times F
of U this is the standard the averaging
it's uh it's
it's actually convenient to think of the
space of functions on the vertices to
have an inner product on it so we like
to have an inner product engine
functions and the vertices but instead
of just usually we say just average over
F of V G of e we want to take the
average with respect to the correct
probability distribution over the
vertices usually if some vertex has a
lot of neighboring edges we want to give
it more weight in this in this
expectation we really should read it
that it's summation over all V of the
probability of a times F of V and of
course you can define normal
and what's nice is that now with respect
to this in your product the operator is
self-adjoint actually I should have an
intermediate what is this really equal
it equals the expectation over choosing
any random edge UV and this expectation
is with respect to the distribution over
edges you write it out and you see this
is the expectation over V of F of V AG
at point V and when you open this up you
see that it equals patient of V F of V
times what is this it's the expectation
over you a neighbor of V G of U this is
by definition of this adjacency operator
and so this is exactly equal to this
right because you first choose a random
neighbor and then you choose a random
vertex and then choose a random neighbor
of it it's exactly like choosing a
random edge and you see here that we
used exactly this reversal that if you
start with the distribution over the
edges and you look at the appropriate
distribution over vertices then it's the
same to choose first an edge and then a
vertex as it is to choose first of our
text and then image so this is used
anyway we get that this a is
self-adjoint which is exactly like we
had in the case of regular graphs you
looked at the adjacency matrix and you
saw that it's symmetric and therefore
you know it's diagonalizable and you had
I gain vectors and eigen values here
it's the same thing you know the
corollary of this is that a can be
there exists corollary is that there is
a basis for the space of function you
know the space of functions on the
vertices any function on the vertices
can be decomposed into eigenfunctions
and we also it's easy to see that the
all the eigenvalues are between plus and
minus 1 and the top eigen function is
the all one's function and so what you
get from this is that I guess what you
get from this is that every every
function
we always like as a constant function so
this is more this you think of it as the
one function times some constant which
is the expectation of F this is the F
zero five and the F perpendicular part
this is a part that has a expectation
zero so the function can be involved
into a constant part and a part that is
orthogonal to zero in this way of
writing it's the constant it's the
constant function this function that has
expectation 0 is exactly the part that
will shrink this one corresponds to
eigenvalue one and this one corresponds
to some other eigen values and if
they're all Bank bounded by some lambda
then this part is the part which what is
our definition of a region of a function
of a graph that has spectral expansion
louder
the eigenvalues are lambda in
one which equals one these are the eigen
values satisfy lambda bounds lambda N
and needs to write it like this
both lambda 2 and lambda n are
sandwiched between lambda and minus
lambda okay
then we say that this is a two-sided a
two-sided lambda expander and the
one-sided lambda expander if I have here
one then I just don't care about this
condition I don't care about bounding it
from one side then I say that it's all a
one-sided London's bounded from both
directions to side so this this is
standard now that we took this effort we
can return to define high dimensional
expanders
is what would be the definition of a
high dimension
yes I have said two-dimensional complex
then the definition will just be that
you want both the skeleton of the
complex to be expanding so when you say
everything it doesn't make sense to look
at links of faces of the top dimension
nor of faces of the dimension one below
if you are a triangle complex and you
look at link of an edge all you see a
bunch of vertices not interesting so
it's always interesting to look at two
dimensions below where I is less than I
need to go down two dimensions is
respect receive but it's okay because we
defined it on the graphs right so we
know what when a graph is a lambda
spectral expander graph what does it
mean to look at two dimensions below you
have top faces have dimension one these
are the edges the faces after that are
dimension zero the vertices and then
there is this dimension minus 1 which is
the empty set so all you're requiring is
that the link of the empty set which is
the entire graph is spectral expander
that's fine you have now a triangle
complex you're requiring that every the
link of every vertex which is now a
graph is along the spectral expander and
maybe I should say the link of a face
I should say so when you look at the
link of a face you get a complex why I
should say is that the graph underlying
the link if I have some complex that has
dimension 3 I can still only look at the
edges and the vertices and I require
that it is one dimension still yes so
you want to always look at any link any
link and look at the one one skeleton of
this link and you want it to be a
spectral expected so this is our
definition if you want to kind of
understand what what this definition
means in the case of a triangle complex
then you need to have tried to draw for
yourself a collection of triangles so
that whenever you look at the vertex and
you look at its link so for example the
link of this vertex is this which is at
least connected but the link of this
vertex is not even connected so to make
it connected I need to add one more
triangle and if you try to construct
this you will see that because you added
this triangle then this vertex now has a
new guy in its link and so you're
forcing more and more and more triangles
it's very difficult to construct a graph
that has constant degree and yet the
link of every vertex is itself an
expander okay and remember that now
because we define this lambda spectral
expander I don't need to talk about an
infinite family even a graph of with ten
vertices there is some meaning to saying
that it's an expander with lambda I
don't know point four we really care
about is to have lambda go there close
as possible to zero one side intercept
okay so thanks so you can make two
definition so if you write here one
sided then you should write here one
sided
variant that is equivalent to the random
walk definition this well I talked about
this morning in your tongue we'll talk
about more in depth
tomorrow is the two-sided so the
two-sided definition although it looks
very different from the random walk
definition it's actually equivalent to
the random walk definition where you
compare the random walks from the lower
and the upper random walks
initially does this comparison is
actually equivalent to the two-sided
okay so
the things I want to do before we
continue is to talk about you know where
does this definition come from these two
things these two questions should be
answered together
really someone from TCS background
wouldn't come up with such a definition
because when you try to see if this
definition makes sense even in the case
of a two dimensional complex it doesn't
seem like it's realizable okay so what
are the tools that we have in our
toolbox to even try to construct such a
thing
so one natural thing to do is to try to
look at random will have this property
if it is very dense maybe actually the
first thing I should say is that look
let's at least see if what Polad called
the gold standard the complete complex
let's let's at least see if that has
this satisfies this definition so what
is the complete complex for example in
the case of a dimension to it say you
have n vertices and you have all n
choose three triangles what is the link
of a vertex so this vertex participates
in triangles with every choice of any
other pair of vertices so when you look
at the link you just get n minus 1
vertices and on them all possible n
minus 1 choose 2 edges so the link of a
vertex doesn't matter which one it's
just a complete graph on n minus 1
vertices so indeed it's a very good
spectral expander at least we know that
the complete complex is indeed a very
good is there any sparse such complex
there is no method that I know that will
brings me that such an object exists and
I think the people who discovered these
objects they they came from group theory
and
kind of their story was it was different
they already knew how to construct
expander graphs based on these groups
the reconstruction so there is this
famous expander graph construction of
liubot tsuki Phillips and Sonic from the
80s okay what they did is they looked at
very good expander which is the infinite
tree and then they found a way to
quotient it and make it into a finite
graph by identifying vertices in this
infinite tree they got a graph that
still has the same spectral behavior as
the infinite tree and that's how they
constructed their famous Ramanujan and
then later on this is the story I was
told so new machinery came about that
showed that quotients of even higher
dimensional objects can be built in our
finite and then the bots key someone's
envision a worked very hard to make out
of these some finite simplicial
complexes and these simplicial complexes
just like the case of the infinite tree
that was caution to the into finite
we're looking at this infinite object
which is the higher dimensional analog
of a tree it's called a building but
it's building look at this infinite
object and manage to to make it into a
finite object it still locally looks
exactly like the infinite object so what
they had now is some simplicial complex
it's finite and each of the links we
know exactly what it looks like it's
actually very easy to describe and you
know what the links are like and you
know that it's a finite object and you
need to work very hard to analyze
exactly what the spectrum is but they
gave it gave them an object and now you
need to come up with kind of interesting
definitions or interesting properties
that this object has and one of them is
is list actually yeah
to further talks to give more details on
this but we see that because of some
group theoretic considerations this
object exists and now you need to
understand what what can we possibly do
with this object so still a looks very
intriguing and I feel like we haven't
yet kind of used it very so now before I
wanted to say that I forgot so right so
what venket is asking is look you made
this definition and in this definition I
require that the link of every face in
every dimension needs to be a land of
spectral expander but there is this
theorem of is how I'll open I'm using
what's called the garland method it
actually shows that you know it's enough
to require this on the very top faces so
dimension D minus 2 if you know that the
link of every face of dimension B minus
2 itself is it's a graph if you know
that this graph is an expander and you
know that the underlying complex is
connected this is enough to kind of have
kind of a trickling down phenomena where
the expansion trip is done to all the
links all the way down and you get you
get this definition you lose something
you start with some lambda and you
slightly lose in the lambda but the loss
is a you know maybe it's a factor of I
or something like that so it's not very
bad this actually your tongue will after
lunch your tongue will show a proof of
this it's
so
I want to finish the last thing I want
to describe before I finish after I
showed this definition and the
definition looks a bit strange but I
want to show some application of this
definition along the lines of this local
to global yes I won't show the
applications of this definition and I
just want to describe to you one result
that follows from having such an object
so as I said before you know the
definition talks about you know you have
a complex and it just tells you look if
I if you tell me that for every link the
neighborhood is expanding then I call
this object a high dimensional expanded
it turns out that one of the key
features of these object is that you
have some local information and from it
you can derive some global data one
example is what we just described this
trickling down theorem just because you
know expansion in every link and you
just need to assume a very weak
connectivity assumption just because of
this local expansion in the links you
get global expansion so another such
application is for lease decoding
we can use the high dimensional
expanders to take an error-correcting
code and to make it into a that is just
unique decodable and to make it into an
aircraft and code that is least
decodable
it's known that you can if you have an
error-correcting code you can use the
expander graphs amplify the distance
suppose you have an error correcting
code on n beats suppose you have an
error correcting code on n bits here are
the envy and look at some expander graph
where the vertices up here are connected
in some expanding way to the vertices
down here that's a very kind of
classical construction of a a B and in
our I think Prahlad mentioned them as
well is to put the the bits of the earth
of the code word here you create a new
code by collecting the symbol so in this
location you will collect the symbols
from all of the neighbors of this guy
okay so now if you had 0 1 & 0 then here
you will write 0 1 & 0
and so on so you kind of aggregate
symbols according to this expander and
you get a new code over a slightly
larger alphabet and this code has much
larger distance because it has much
larger distance you can maybe hope to
get better decoding ability of this loop
so we don't know how to do it in general
but if it so happens that these vertices
are really the D faces some high
dimensional expander and if this high
dimensional expander really came from
some K dimensions so here are the K
faces in case
then you can look at kind of the
subgraph that is underneath this cafes
Vista called each part separately and
then you use this expansion property of
the links to combine these lists into
one big code word so what you're doing
here is using the fact that this say a
dimensional expander can be broken down
into small parts each part you can list
the code maybe exhaustively just by
going over all the possibilities because
it has constant size then you have some
resulting list you have many many lists
and then you need to kind of stitch
these things together and similarly to
these agreement tested parado showing
the stitching is possible because we
know how to analyze these random walks
so I mean I know this is very hand wavy
maybe we will have a talk about this
this is by the way joint work with say
valid and Kali Kaufman in value evening
your phone and I'm Natasha just wanted
to show you one application of these
high dimensional expanders that relates
to codes by allowing you to zoom in on a
small part and do some work so that
doesn't cost you a lot and then to
stitch the the parts together anyway
I'll stop here and your tongue will
continue
[Applause]
the last application talk about the
mystic